[Applause]
four thousand people have climbed to the
top of Mount Everest and 562 have been
to space but only seven have made it to
the bottom of the Mariana Trench are you
ready to join that exclusive club almost
11 kilometres below sea level it's the
deepest location on earth and getting
there is not going to be easy
not only will things get cold in dark
very fast but you'll also be facing a
deadly amount of water pressure the
water pressure at the bottom of the
trench is over 1,100 kilograms per
square centimeter that's about 1,000
times the pressure you feel at sea level
with extreme conditions like these how
has anyone made it to the bottom and
lived to tell the tale here's how to
survive diving down the Mariana Trench
you would never make it to the bottom of
the ocean without any equipment because
you would run out of oxygen and your
body would be shut down by the pressure
underwater so if you want any chance of
surviving this journey you'll need some
sort of capsule to bring you safely to
the bottom but what would this capsule
look like would you be able to make it
back to the surface and what features
what it needs to survive the extreme
conditions
number one the ability to withstand
pressure how will you know what your
capsule will need to bring you to the
bottom of the Mariana Trench safely well
let's take a look at two capsules that
have already made the journey the DSV
limiting factor and the deep-sea
challenger about 70 percent of the
deep-sea challengers volume is made up
of something called syntactic foam
[Music]
syntactic foam is the only floatation
material that can withstand the
incredible pressures in the Mariana
Trench it's made up of millions of
hollow glass microspheres suspended in a
paste-like substance called an epoxy
resin not only does this material have
the strength to withstand the constant
pressure it also has the low density
required to keep the capsule buoyant if
you didn't have this sort of protection
you'd fall victim to the high pressure
levels pretty quickly the pressure from
the water would push in on your body
causing any space that's filled with air
to collapse
including your lungs at the same time
the pressure from the water would push
water into your mouth filling your lungs
back up again with water instead of air
number two the ability to return to the
surface it's one thing to be able to
make it down to the bottom of the
Mariana Trench but it's even more
important to be able to make it back up
to sea level the deep-sea challenger has
450 kilograms of steel weights attached
to either side of it to ensure that it
will sink to the bottom and then
whenever you're ready to return to the
surface you can simply release the
weights but what if you encounters some
sort of emergency well if there's a
power failure the weights will drop
automatically and if you have a support
team at the surface they could command
the weights to drop as well there's also
a special wire that attaches the weights
to the sub that will corrode after 11 to
13 hours in seawater just in case number
three an oxygen supply your submarine
capsule is a sealed container that has a
limited supply of air if you want to
keep that air breathable here are two
main things that need to happen for one
thing the oxygen has to be replenished
as you use it if the percentage of
oxygen in the air falls too low then
you're going to suffocate also the
carbon dioxide needs to be removed from
the air if the concentration of carbon
dioxide Rises it will become toxic the
DSV limiting factors air supply consists
of a rack of oxygen cylinders and a
system that operates like a small planet
the carbon dioxide you exhale into your
capsule is removed by devices called
carbon scrubbers they clean the air
allowing you to breathe it again
basically you would be breathing the
same air over and over again this gives
you an oxygen supply that will last for
an impressive 16 hours
along with an emergency backup that will
last an additional 96 hours number 4
long battery life when you make your
journey down to the depths of the ocean
you're going to be relying entirely on
battery power so make sure you've got a
lot of it the deep-sea challenger has
about 70 bread-loaf sized battery packs
inside oil filled plastic boxes mounted
into the sub sides
the batteries are spaced just far enough
apart that they won't be disrupted when
the foam structure that they sit in
shrinks by about 1% under the ocean's
pressure having a lot of batteries isn't
just important for the obvious stuff
like controlling the ship
there are also dedicated battery systems
for search and rescue purposes for
example one battery system is completely
dedicated to powering LED lights that
can assist a recovery team trying to
find the capsule when it returns to the
surface so there you have it
surviving the trip down to the Mariana
Trench is pretty easy as long as you can
afford a fancy submarine some companies
are even starting to bring tourists down
there
and don't worry if you're scared of
getting trapped underwater well we've
got just the video to help you calm
those fears
[Music]